У той час, як завдяки карантину повітря у багатьох європейських мегаполісах стало чистішим,
у Києві цього року навпаки - кілька разів реєстрували рекордну забрудненість повітря.
Смог над Києвом нависає час від часу не лише через лісові пожежі на Київщині чи Житомирщині.
Постійними забруднювачами повітря в Києві є підприємства енергетики і автотранспорт.
І якщо викиди з ТЕЦ  як-не-як контролюються з боку Держекоінспекції, то викиди від автотранспорту не регулює ніхто.
90 відсотків усіх викидів у Києві - це саме від автотранспорту.
Що робить влада і як вона на це реагує?
Якщо згадати минулорічну осінь, дуже багато говорили про якість повітря і як це треба покращувати.
От рік минув, і ми таку ж саму ситуацію маємо.
У КМДА з цим не згодні. Тут звітують про висадження упродовж двох років понад 40000 кущів та дерев,
втілення програм з озеленення прибудинкових територій, а також розчистку Дніпра
задля збільшення можливості річкової води поглинати забруднюючі речовини.
Проте екоактивісти вважають, що цих заходів - критично мало.
Вони радять київській владі звернути увагу на досвід інших європейських столиць,
які реагують на підвищені показники забруднення повітря зменшенням кількості автомобілів у середмісті.
Київській міській владі ніхто не заважає вплинути на якість повітря в той момент,
коли рівень забруднення повітря є високим. Що вона може зробити?
Обмежити кількість авто в цей день або обмежити використання транспорту
на дизельному паливі, підвищити ціну за паркування.
У КМДА погоджуються, що такі кроки доцільні. Як розповіли DW у київському Департаменті екології,
заходи щодо регулювання кількості автотранспорту в Києві відповідно до показників забруднення повітря
мали бути затверджені ще депутатами минулого скликання Київради.
Цьому буцімто завадила пандемія.
Тепер у Департаменті очікують, що відповідну стратегію ухвалять новообрані депутати.
До літа має бути ухвалене якесь рішення, щоб обмежити рух транспорту в складні періоди,
коли дійсно є загроза дуже поганого атмосферного повітря. Варіантів декілька.
Це за номерами автомобілів. Приміром, якщо починаються на одиницю, то сьогодні вони не виїжджають.
Якщо починається на двійку, то не виїжджають наступного дня.
Або це може бути по масивах, коли, наприклад, з Лісового масиву
сьогодні автотранспорт не рухається до центру через мости, через великі магістралі.
Деякі заходи точково вже навіть протестували. Приміром, на вулицях Саксаганського і  Жилянській
запровадили однобічний рух саме з міркувань меншого забруднення повітря.
Улітку обмежувався також в’їзд вантажівок та дизельних авто - не лише, щоб ті не руйнували дороги,
а й щоб не збільшували викиди в повітря.
Ще одна прогалина в урядуванні української столиці, на яку вказують захисники довкілля, -
це відсутність чіткої стратегії, як зробити громадський транспорт більш екологічним.
Громадський транспорт має бути електрифікований і прямолінійний,
щоб було зручно користуватися. І потрібен розвиток мікромобільності -
це використання велосипедів, самокатів, моноколес. Вони можуть взяти на себе до 15% усіх поїздок.
Рік тому Кличко обіцяв киянам до 2023-го року придбати 400 одиниць електротранспорту:
трамваїв, тролейбусів і електробусів. Як повідомили DW в пресслужбі Департаменту транспорту,
нині обговорюється можливість придбання у новому році чотирьох електробусів.
Але такі плани наразі ще вилами по воді писані. DW не змогли відповісти ні щодо виробників цих електробусів,
ні скільки вони коштуватимуть. Відомо, що в міському бюджеті на наступний рік на це гроші не закладені,
і мерія шукає додаткові джерела фінансування.
Виконувач обов’язків начальника Департаменту екології КМДА не довіряє міжнародним онлайн-рейтингам,
згідно з якими Київ не раз потрапляв у компанію таких світових забруднювачів повітря, як Пекін чи Делі.
КМДА хоче запровадити свій аналіз якості повітря.
Для цього мають встановити 22 пункти спостереження за якістю повітря у наступні два-три роки.
Наразі вже встановлено два пункти, що працюють у тестовому режимі.
У дні, коли Київ був серед антилідерів-забруднювачів,
вони не демонстрували серйозного перевищення норм.
Наше обладнання зі спеціальним пробовідбірником, який висушує повітря від вологи -
і тільки потім його вимірює і підігріває до відвідної температури.
Тому якщо відкрити наш ресурс, то пил в межах норми.
Загалом якість повітря в Києві переважну більшість року відповідає нормативам.
Тим часом, за даними Державної геофізичної обсерваторії, яка має в Києві 16 пунктів спостереження,
у грудні показники максимально допустимих норм шкідливих речовин у повітрі щодня перевищують норми.
Приміром, діоксиду азоту - в 3 рази, формальдегіду - більш ніж у півтори, діоксиду сірки - вдвічі.
Показники вкрай шкідливого для здоров'я дрібнодисперсного пилу також час від часу хоч і не драматично,
але перевищували допустимий рівень.
Викиди дрібнодисперсного пилу в атмосферу пов'язують також з роботою вугільних ТЕС.
Через це в Європі нині намагаються повністю від них відмовитися.
Але у порівнянні з автотранспортом усі київські ТЕС і ТЕЦ разом з промисловими підприємствами
викидають в атмосферу менше дрібнодисперсного пилу, ніж автівки.
На Дарницькій вугільній ТЕЦ DW продемонстрували один з нових електрофільтрів,
що вбирає дрібнодисперсні продукти згорання від вугілля. Ідеться про тонни токсичних речовин.
Залежить від якості палива. За місяць це 1500 тонн,
якщо на повній потужності будуть один-два котли працювати.
Тому ми уловлюємо пил, транспортуємо в силос, і потім це далі використовується
як вторсировина для будівельної галузі.
Активісти регулярно критикують Дарницьку ТЕЦ через забруднення повітря діоксидом сірки
і діоксидом азоту, а також продуктами згоряння вугілля.
Однак на самій ТЕЦ запевняють, що працюють за всіма нормами і дозволами.
А необхідну очисну техніку встановлюють за свій кошт.
Дозволу ми не перевищуємо.
Навпаки. Ми зараз проводимо реконструкцію газоочисного обладнання,
встановлюємо електрофільтри і знижуємо викиди твердих речовин, тобто золи.
Якщо брати один котел, на якому з 2018-го року встановлено електрофільтр,
то зниження майже у 80 разів.
Нешкідливою для довкілля така ТЕЦ ніколи не стане, каже її директор.
Її можна лише закрити, якщо Україна перейде на альтернативні джерела енергії.
Захисники довкілля стверджують, що об’єктивної системи моніторингу викидів в атмосферу
в Україні нині немає - і це лякає.
Теплові електростанції та заводи фактично самі себе моніторять.
А контроль за викидами автотранспорту не відбувається навіть на рівні техоглядів,
які були скасовані ще в 2011 році.
Рейди з перевірки викидів автомобілів ні поліція, ні "Укртрансбезпека" не проводять.
Тим часом, за даними ВООЗ, за рівнем смертності через забруднення повітря
Україна посідає 15-те місце у світі і п'яте в Європі - після  Боснії і Герцеговини, Чорногорії, Грузії і Болгарії.
Це 120 смертей на 100 000 населення.